Hi, this is Dr. Liat
Jarkhan. I'm the
Director of the Center
for Behavioral Health,
Associate Professor,
Department
of Family
Medicine at NYIT
College of
Osteopathic Medicine.
Today, I'm gonna
be talking to
you about personality
disorders,
trying to debunk
some myths,
understand and clarify
the differences,
and also talk about
how it affects
us personally as
well as clinically.
At the end of
this session,
you should be able to
understand the common
symptoms of each
personality disorder and
why they're assigned
within their cluster,
develop an understanding
of how personality
disorders impact
relationships, and
apply this knowledge
to clinical scenarios.
First, let's identify
what personality
disorders are.
According to the DSM-5,
a personality
disorder is defined as
a pattern of inner
experience and behavior
that deviates
markedly from the
expectations of the
individual's culture.
The pattern is enduring,
inflexible, and
pervasive across a broad
range of personal and
social situations.
There are 10
identified personality
disorders, which
are categorized
into three clusters,
A, B, and C,
based on descriptive
similarities.
Individuals may
present with
co-occurring
personality disorders
from different clusters.
Personality
Disorder Markers
A personality
disorder must be
presented by
early adulthood.
Most personality
disorders cannot
be diagnosed
in individuals
under the age of
18 years of age,
unless the characteristics
have been present
for over a year.
One exception is
antisocial personality
disorder, which cannot
be diagnosed until the
age of 18, but before
18, it's considered
a conduct disorder.
The diagnosis of
personality disorders
requires evaluation
of one's long-term
pattern of functioning
over time and across
different situations.
The personality
traits identified
must be distinguished
from personality
traits which may emerge
only during
exceptionally stressful
periods, exclusively
during the onset of other
mental health episodes,
or co-occurring
during an episode
of substance *****.
Let's move on to
personality disorder
demographics. A clinician
cannot accurately
diagnose an individual
with a personality
disorder without
first taking into
account their ethnic,
cultural, and social
background as norms
vary across cultures.
The clinician should
utilize informants
who are familiar
with the individual's
culture, such as
family and friends.
Some personality
disorders have been
socially stereotyped by
gender. As an example,
males are more
frequently diagnosed with
antisocial personality
disorders, and
females with borderline
dependent and
histrionic personality
disorders. Clinicians
must remain objective to
avoid overgeneralizing
based on this
societal perception.
Let's start
with the cluster
A personality disorders.
The disorders in
this cluster all have
the following
hallmarks. Individuals
appear to be, quote,
odd or eccentric.
It's related to psychotic
disorders of paranoid,
schizoid, and
schizotypal.
The pattern of
behavior does not occur
exclusively during
the course of a
psychotic disorder,
such as schizophrenia,
bipolar disorder,
or depression
with psychotic features.
If an individual has
a persistent mental
disorder, for example,
schizophrenia, and has
had a pre-existing
personality disorder, it
should be documented
as being pre-morbid.
Let's start out
with paranoid
personality disorder.
The characteristics
in this
disorder include
being distrustful
and suspicious of others,
interpreting
the motives of
others as being
malevolent,
being guarded,
reluctant to confide
in others for fear
of retribution.
They can be very
controlling in
relationships for fear
of being betrayed,
and they may be
pathologically jealous.
In addition, they
tend to overreact
with anger, and
they're quick
to counterattack
when insulted.
Let's move on to schizoid
personality disorder.
In this personality
disorder,
characteristics include
being detached from
social relationships
by preference.
Restricted range of
expression of emotions.
They have little interest
in intimacy. They
lack friends or
confidence, but they're
indifferent to praise
or criticism of others.
They're perfectly
happy to not be in the
midst of other people.
It's their choice.
Moving on to schizotypal
personality disorder.
Individuals with this
disorder tend to have
odd beliefs or magical
thinking that's
inconsistent with
societal cultural norms.
For example, they tend
to be superstitious,
have a sixth sense or
belief in telepathy.
They have unusual
perceptions
such as ****** illusions.
They could
have odd speech
patterns such
as being vague,
circumstantial, or
over-elaborative.
And they can be
eccentric, peculiar
in appearance
and behavior. It
was cluster A. Let's
move on to cluster B
personality disorders.
So in cluster B,
the hallmarks that
these disorders have in
common include being
dramatic, emotional,
erratic.
It's related to mood
disorders, substance
*****, and
somatoform disorders.
But the pattern
of behavior does
not occur
exclusively during
the course of a
mood disorder,
substance use disorder,
or somatoform disorder.
So let's start out with
antisocial personality
disorder. The main
characteristics of this
disorder include
lacking conforming to
social norms, for example,
criminal behaviors,
having a complete
disregard for and violation
of the rights of
others, being dishonest,
irresponsible,
lacking remorse, and
the diagnosis of conduct
disorder is onset
before the age of 15.
Pretty good indicator
that someone
is evolving
into having an
antisocial
personality disorder.
Of note, these individuals
are colloquially
referred to as
psychopaths or sociopaths.
Let's move on to
borderline personality
disorder. This is a
disorder which is often
very misunderstood
and spoken about
colloquially. So let's
clarify what this is. The
main characteristics
of this personality
disorder include being
unstable and having
very unstable and
intense relationships.
They also split, and
splitting is defined
as alternating
between idealizing and
devaluing an individual,
but also in provoking
between two or
more individuals or
providers with the goal
of polarizing them on
treatment decisions
which undermine the
therapeutic process,
being manipulative.
But it doesn't have to
be just therapeutic.
It could be in a
social setting as well.
Intense fear of
abandonment, recurrent
suicidal behavior,
gestures, threats,
and self-harm,
such as cutting,
incredibly
emotionally labile,
a lot of mood lability,
chronically
feeling empty,
having transient
periods of paranoia
or severe
dissociative symptoms,
and having an
unstable self-image.
They also possess
impulsivity in at
least two areas,
such as spending,
being ********
promiscuous, substance
*****, reckless driving,
and binge eating.
Another personality
disorder in this
cluster is histrionic
personality disorder.
Characteristics
of this disorder
include being
excessively emotional,
excessive
attention-seeking,
being ********
provocative,
dramatic, theatrical,
being easily
influenced by others,
having superficial
relationships,
And note, they often
have difficulty in
maintaining successful
intimate relationships.
That includes
people with any
significant personality
disorder, but this
group in particular,
this cluster.
And next, let's
talk about
narcissistic
personality disorder.
The main characteristics
of this disorder
include a grandiose
sense of self-importance,
lacking empathy,
seeking excessive
admiration,
sense of entitlement,
being preoccupied with
fantasies of
unlimited success,
power,
beauty, fame, and
love, ideal love,
exploiting others,
being jealous
of others and
believing that
others are jealous of
them, and possessing
arrogance.
that rounds
off cluster B.
Let's move on
to cluster C.
The hallmarks of cluster
C are anxiety and fear.
They're related to
anxiety disorders,
but the pattern
of behavior
does not occur
exclusively during
the course of an
anxiety disorder.
So let's take a look
at some of these
personality disorders.
Let's start off with
avoidant personality
disorder. Someone with
this personality
disorder is socially
inhibited. They feel
inadequate. They're extremely
oversensitive to
rejection or criticism.
They fear being
embarrassed or ridiculed.
And so they're reluctant
to take personal risks.
important to know
the difference that
individuals with avoidant
personality disorder want
to make friends, but
they're hypersensitive
to rejection, while
the individuals with
schizoid personality
disorder that we talked
about earlier from
cluster A prefer to be
alone and are indifferent
to criticism or
complaints. These
individuals with avoidant
personality disorder,
they're upset about it.
Let's move on
to dependent
personality disorder.
So individuals with
dependent personality
disorder tend to
be submissive and
clingy in behavior.
They fear separating.
It's difficult for
them to make daily
decisions. They seek
excessive reassurance.
They have difficulty
disagreeing because
they're afraid of
losing support.
They lack confidence, so
they fear
initiating ideas.
They have fears
of being alone
due to unrealistic
fear of being
unable to care
for themselves.
Individuals with
this category may
unfortunately end up
in toxic relationships,
being easily manipulated
and taken advantage of.
Next, let's talk
about obsessive
compulsive
personality disorder.
There's a mnemonic,
O-N-O, O-N-O. O
stands for orderly,
N for neat and
perfectionistic, and
O also for obstinate,
stubborn, and rigid
with routines.
It's really
important to know the
difference between
OCPD and OCD.
Individuals with OCPD,
obsessive compulsive
personality disorder,
do not feel like
they have an issue.
It's called egocentonic.
Whereas individuals
with OCD,
obsessive
compulsive disorder,
they know they
have an issue.
And this is called
egodystonic.
So that rounds off
cluster C. Additionally,
in addition
to clusters A,
B, and C, there
are other personality
disorders.
And characteristics
of these include
change due to the direct
effect of a medical
condition. And I'm
also going to add
maybe a reaction to
some medications.
The personality observed
is a change from
the individual's
previously typical
personality pattern,
and the changes cause
significant distress
in functioning.
There was an example
a few years back.
Certain strep infections
were associated with
an increase in OCD
symptoms in some children.
When treated with
appropriate antibiotic
intervention, the OCD
symptoms remitted.
These disorders were
called the PANDAS,
which stands for
Pediatric Autoimmune
Neuropsychiatric
Disorders Associated
with Streptococcal
Infection.
So in summary,
each personality disorder
has a set of their
own common symptoms,
as well as shared
hallmark characteristics
of their assigned
clusters. You should
become familiar with those.
Having a
personality disorder
can create
significant strain
on interpersonal
relationships.
Once they're identified,
you may be able
to intervene
therapeutically to have the
individual with the
disorder understand it
as well as their
significant other or
family members so that
they can understand
how to better
communicate and what this
individual's needs are
and restrictions are.
The core references
that we discussed
include medical
knowledge and its
application to osteopathic
medical practice,
osteopathic
patient care and
interpersonal and
communication skills
in osteopathic
medical practice.
Please don't forget
to fill out and
submit your student
feedback form and
if you have any
questions about this
lecture, any
information in the
lecture, please feel
free to reach out.
Thank you for your time.